on a scale of one to ten how romantic is
season four of Chesapeake shores it's
it's very romantic I would say it's a 10
a 10 is tres gonna make a bold move race
is all about bold he's gonna make the
ultimate bold move face is all about
Abby it's good to see you
can you set us up a little bit we're two
season for pickup well tres comes back
from tour to just be sure you know his
communication with Abby has become less
and less over the last few months on
tour he's compelled to leave the tour
early come back Chesapeake shores and
you know try to salvage that
relationship and when he comes back he
finds out that uh you know he's not he's
not welcome necessarily the way he
thought he would be how is he dealing
with that cuz I got to imagine you know
it's so hard to balance work with
personal right it's difficult but I
think he understands that he's he was
basically given an ultimatum you know by
Abby and he chose his career and he
chose the band and he has to respect the
fact that she doesn't want to be on the
on the roller the emotional roller
coaster
yes I'm here to stay it would be
different this time but I can't go back
it looks like he's gonna be fighting for
what he wants and that's Abby how much
of that are we gonna see this season is
it a whole push and pull day you know
what sometimes fighting for something is
knowing when the respect boundaries so I
think he has to respect her boundaries
and at the same time you know try on the
idea of you know living his life without
her and that's where these new love
interests come to come into the story
you know this season both Tracey and
Abby you know relationships with other
people okay so that opens a whole nother
can of worms what is in store for trace
as far as another love partner well he's
definitely not not looking for that and
he realizes that he's still
very much in love with Abby but uh you
know this this new very interesting
person starts working at the bridge they
have a lot in common and you know things
kind of take on a life of their own
her name's Emma and she's also a singer
there's chemistry there as well so hard
to fight it when it's right in front of
you times win it win it when it's right
and the shoe fits it's difficult to
resist the chess ease they are so
diehard Travie it's like not even funny
so what is your message to fans or maybe
a little apprehensive about seeing tres
with someone who's not a B well I think
we Chesapeake shores we're really trying
to tell a very grounded real story and I
think sometimes the hallmark ease you
know tend to live in this utopian world
which you know that's just not really
the story were telling here we're
telling we're telling a story about real
life you know and I there's eggs and
flows and real life and and things are
not always perfect but if something's
meant to be then it will be where do you
see traces heart hootie-hoo would you
like him to ultimately end up with well
I think trace is hard is always going to
be with Abby yeah their end game I try
be as endgame I think so talk to me
particularly about your friendship with
Megan and working with her how is it
that you guys foster such amazing
chemistry it's a lot easier if you have
a an admiration for the person you're
working opposite and I definitely admire
Megan I think she's a she's a great
person you know and a great actor and
and we work well together
most important person in my life I
figure this time I show you
I know it's hard juggling a career with
a personal life and you make a lot of
sacrifices I think especially with what
you do for a living how is it that you
balance that in your own life wow that's
that's a great question you know I love
what I do so I'm not struggling with
balance I'm also in a long-term
relationship with someone who
understands the demands of this business
I know that you're spending a month's
you know on set and traveling here and I
know Cara's got a business schedule what
we trow the keys not to go longer than
two weeks without seeing each other
some people can handle it and some
people can but we have a rock-solid
relationship jesse proposed to his
longtime love actress kara Santana in
August 2016 he explained to ET why they
haven't quite made it to the altar just
yet has there been a date set yeah
several times okay what keeps pushing it
work really yeah so some big work
obligation comes up in all the time you
know all the time work opportunities
really come up and we just kind of like
we just push it I don't know if we're
like Kurt Russell and Goldie Hawn or
what the situation is that works it
works for us for now Jesse said they're
focused on being each other's biggest
cheerleaders we even asked Cara to help
us out with this interview by submitting
a question of her own we want to know
what is the thing
the most when you're on location filming
Chesapeake shores - my my family you
know that's what we said we you know we
call our you know us as a couple and our
two dogs are a little our little family
she's the best yeah she's my biggest fan
she's super supportive we support each
other through thick and thin and you
know it helps to have someone to come
home to kind of like just you know
download on your day you know share the
trials and tribulations with if you had
to describe season four of Chesapeake
Shores in three adjectives what would it
be
dramatic romantic and musical because
there's some amazing new music this
season duets I mean amazing new songs
it's gonna be a great season it's got a
tall
[Applause]